[Musique]
et bienvenue sur tv 78 que vous nous
suiviez sur votre téléviseur votre
ordinateur votre smart smart phones que
ce soit en direct ou que ce soit en
différé nous sommes le 22 mars
aujourd'hui édition spéciale dans le
cadre des universités des mairies des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine en des
vous annuel qui pour 2021 se déroulera
uniquement en ligne pour les
collectivités de l'ouest parisien
plusieurs tables rondes sont prévues
informations sur le site universités des
mairies point fr à cette occasion tv 78
vous propose donc tout au long de cet
après midi une série d'émissions avec
vos élus locaux nous débutons par une
première séquence en compagnie de
pierrefonds bonjour président de
l'association la dmr des yvelines et
votre homologue dans les hauts-de-seine
jacques kossowski bienvenue également
ses présidents donc de cette association
pour le 92
bonjour également à sophie primas qui
est en ligne avec nous bonjour sophie
primas sénatrice des yvelines qui
interviendra donc en ligne vous
représenter aujourd'hui le président du
sénat gérard larcher pierrefonds pour
débuter important de maintenir ce rendez
vous en ligne 100% virtuel mais mais
nécessaire malgré tout assez
indispensable
alors moi je préfère le présentiel comme
beaucoup comme beaucoup d'élus
d'ailleurs parce que on fait passer les
choses un peu différemment mais c'était
indispensable de le faire en s'adaptant
aux règles sanitaires et bien sûr cette
question de distance voilà jackowski
c'est la première fois véritablement que
78 92 sont pleinement associés pour ces
universités donc merci d'abord à pierre
de me recevoir
parce qu'elle est chez lui puis merci
aussi en même temps à vous oui c'est
important je crois que
cela n'engage pas l'avenir je me suis
très prudent mais oui c'est intéressant
bien entendu 68 92 se rapproche c'est
une bonne chose
vous travaillez déjà en commun ont
peut-être aussi commencer par ça 78 92 à
nancy conserve donc afin de souffler
puisque n'est pas une opposition
successifs qui était devedjian donc
avait déjà commencé à se rapprocher de
bédié bédié tout le monde serre conchil
yade quand même 3 d action commun mais
moi je ne suis pas au conseil
départemental donc ça m'est difficile
qui a peut-être pour en parler plus
facilement que moi mais oui c'est vrai
c'est déjà des actions qui sont en
commune
oui il ya des services qui sont partagé
d'ailleurs on sera mesure on a essayé de
mettre en sorte les moyens et les
compétences ensemble ça fonctionne
plutôt bien et puis c'est vrai qu'il ya
une unité de territoire mais en tout cas
il ya d'une très grande proximité entre
le de tatouage était la semaine dernière
en train de voir les travaux d'une d'une
passerelle côté d'eole pour les vélos et
je me rappelais en hommage à patrick
devedjian qui avait accepté d'en
financer une belle partie alors que
c'était plutôt d'ailleurs un équipement
intéressant pour les yvelines enfin
voila c'est des actions très concrètes
qui sont donnés et qui sont menées par
nos deux départements
vous avez l'heure actuelle et les
difficultés que nous avons dans nos
finances partout quelqu'un de choix je
crois qu'on a tout intérêt à être
ensemble pour arriver à en commun pour
faire des économies
parce que vous pouvez très bien ils ont
maîtrisé vos dépenses mais vous
maîtrisez pas vos recettes
donc c'est vraiment une des solutions
nous sommes ensemble pour une heure
presque pour cette ouverture des
universités des mairies du 78 du 92 il
ya une thématique sur cette première
émission rendez vous que nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui c'est l'importance
des élus locaux dans cette gestion de
crise que nous traversons aujourd'hui ce
sont les élus locaux qui sont en
première ligne
sophie primas sénatrice quel regard vous
portez sur ses élus ses mers ses
conseillers municipaux qui aujourd'hui
sont plus que jamais sollicitée depuis
plus d'un an maintenant bien merci merci
beaucoup de m'avoir invité dans cette
dans ce lancement universités mrd
vertement permettez-moi d'abord de
saluer les deux présidents j'allais dire
pardon jacques d'abord café puisque de
notre nouveau président de notre
département mais aussi jacques avec qui
j'ai eu plaisir de partager quelques
moments à l'assemblée nationale il ya
quelques temps
évidemment sur la route le rôle des élus
locaux dans la crise sanitaire nous nous
comprenons ici je crois que c'est une
magnifique illustration du pouvoir de
voir et de la nécessité d'avoir des élus
de proximité qui sont au plus près des
territoires et qui sont à peu près
j'allais dire avec le préfet et ses
services départementaux les jeunes à
comprendre la diversité et la réalité
des territoires au plus près nos
concitoyens et à les appliquer et nous
voyons bien qu'à chaque fois qu'on donne
la main aux abus de kehl et toi ce
soient les mêmes que ce soit aussi je le
répète ça faisait déconcentrés de l'état
et bien nous avons une forme
d'efficacité les initiatives
d'innovation dans l'action et une forme
déficience est donc plus que jamais s'il
devait y avoir quelque chose qui
illustre la nécessité de retrouver une
loi de décentralisation puissante et
bien cette crise
comme pour d'autres choses étaient
vraiment révélateur un élément
révélateur pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens pose la même question aux
deux présidents de département pour les
mères que vous représentez vous en
sortir elle la même chose c'est que
aujourd'hui on voit plus que jamais leur
importance de ces élus de première ligne
oui alors fait c'est à dire c'est pas
une surprise parce qu'en fait à la fois
dans le quotidien et encore plus quand
nous sommes collectivement confrontés à
des situations difficiles
l'échelon municipal et l'échelon
essentiel c'est l'échelon de la
connaissance du terrain et des habitants
c'est aussi la capacité d'avoir des
relations avec les représentants de
l'état
avec également un département et région
et puis c'est aussi
le plus courant à la population et la
population nous connaît quelle que soit
la taille de la ville il ya une relation
ces personnels entre les habitants et
les maires et puis surtout on le voit en
comparaison avec d'autres structures en
particulier de l'état
la chaîne de commandement ces jeunes
gens pour un acteur militaire est
beaucoup plus courte et donc les
décisions peuvent être prises beaucoup
plus rapidement
beaucoup plus concrètement et tout ça ce
sont des éléments encore plus utile
quand on est en situation de crise ou de
pandémie majoritaire la chose suivante
s'il n'y avait pas les élus comment
aujourd'hui serions nous vraiment faut
regarder surtout comme on faisait perdre
dans cette crise aujourd'hui si vous
n'aviez pas les élus pour la vaccination
pour tout ce qui concerne disons à santé
ça manquerait donc on secteur soit
vraiment et la population nous reconnaît
d'ailleurs puisque depuis nous sommes
j'ai lu on a été élu je pense 195 en
même temps on est toujours reconduit ça
veut dire qu'on a fait notre travail on
vous êtes vous n'êtes pas élu si vous ne
faites pas votre travail
surtout que ses proches et si les
dijonnais les administrations pas
content quand vous êtes dans la rue ça
vous appeler par contre ils vont pas
appelé le premier ministre le poison des
publics on est très proche on vous
parlait de cette gestion de crise avec
les centres de dépistage dans un premier
temps centres de vaccination ensuite et
en parallèle puisque les centres de
dépistage aussi sont toujours ouverts
commencés élus locaux ont géré tout ça
je propose de faire une petite pause de
regarder ce reportage préparé par la
rédaction de tv 78 avec célia n 4
secondes cela fait deux mois maintenant
que dix premiers centres de vaccination
ont vu le jour dans les yvelines sur
décision du préfet du département
toute l'organisation logistique
matérielle et humaine repose sur les
communes et les collectivités
territoriales
même si l'état prend en charge la
logistique des dos ce ne sont plus les
préfectures qui gère l'organisation des
centres de vaccination sur les
territoires comme cela a pu être le cas
au moment de la crise h1n1
il ya ensuite le fait qu'une telle
centralisation et donc c'est aussi à
nous en nos responsabilités et d'être la
prochaine bulle vers ceux qui ont lu les
ressources matérielles et même une
organisation importante pour les mairies
qui doivent gérer les listes d'attentes
en fonction des doses disponibles
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
compte 270 habitants mille personnes
sont sur liste d'attenté
la seule ville de versailles je vous
avouerai que c'est ça un peu
complexifier les choses mais parce qu'il
ya deux entrées possibles donc par
l'application pour le site autolib
et puis par des listes d'attentes qui
sont constituées dans les mairies autre
difficulté pour les communes trouver du
personnel soignant disponibles sont des
nains eux mêmes
submergé par les différentes vagues
pandémiques donc c'est à nous de
réaliser cet encadrement sanitaire un
encadrement administratif avec nos
personnels de la ville et puis on n'y a
joué également du bénévolat et c'est
grâce à toutes ces forces volontaire que
les mairies peuvent réagir rapidement
comme lors du week-end du 6 et 7 mars ou
cinq mille doses supplémentaires ont été
distribués dans les différents centres
ça voulait dire quand quelques heures et
je dis bien en quelques heures il
fallait prendre la décision d'ouvrir le
vélodrome durant le week-end ce qui
n'était pas le cas jusqu'à présent
mais c'est pas tout de l'ouvrir ça veut
dire qu'il faut des médecins il faut des
infirmières et infirmiers quatre
nouveaux centres ont ouvert il ya deux
semaines dans les yvelines à
saint-cyr-l'ecole sartrouville très
tiers et les minimes voilà pour cette
illustration de gestion de crise par ses
élus locaux en ligne toujours avec nous
sophie primas sénatrice des yvelines les
deux présidents des associations des
maires des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine est justement puisque
l'on parle de cette gestion de crise
sanitaire est ce que vous vous sentez
accompagné justement par les services de
l'état aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr mais en vous écoutant je me
reproche t en mars dernier parce que
avant le test de l'épisode de masques il
ya eu tous en fait il a fallu équiper
nos services avec des masques je vais
d'ailleurs remercié roselyne bachelot je
sais qu'elle est positive aux corridas
de moi je les remercie parce que les
premiers masques qu'on a utilisées c'est
celle que est ce qu'on recueille nous
avait fait acheter
au nom du h1n1 et qui était encore
valable et donc on vise à recycler et
c'est donc on a été tout au long de
l'année
confrontées à des pénuries accompagné
bien sûr et la relation avec les
services de l'état et une relation qui
est excellente mais on peut s'interroger
aussi sur la réduction de présence de
l'état sur nos territoires
le fait que les préfectures les ars etc
ont relativement peu de moyens
aujourd'hui et que par conséquent on est
dans une situation où les communes très
souvent sont pas laissés seuls mais en
tout cas sont de loin en première ligne
même si elles peuvent s'appuyer sur les
préfets les sous-préfets mais tout ça
c'est une chaîne et cette pandémie a
montré que cette chaîne est extrêmement
fragile pour les masques et c'était très
simple à partir du moment où
gouvernement avait dit il faut des
masques tout le monde est déjà très bien
on va voir des masques et puis on frappe
à la porte du maire ou son monsieur le
maire masquer ce qui arrive quand qu'est
ce qu'on s'était dit on va regarder dans
le territoire qui ont atterri par polt
de 11 communes
est-ce que nous pouvons acheter les
matches qui est effectivement
financièrement vous avons pu en avait
commandé cent cinq mille masques pour la
population et j'étais ravi parce que
s'il n'avait pas les masques c'étaient
les médecins qui n'avaient pas de base
et les infirmières qui avait pas de
masque était même les hôpitaux n'y avait
pas de masque et donc on a pu permettre
cela si on attend de l'état
très honnêtement on a rien qui reste
dans ses fonctions régaliennes qui me
laisse faire le reste
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
facilité et zélie de terrain pour
travailler c'est ça on sait faire
sophie primas il faut laisser les élus
travailler sur le terrain ceux qui sont
plus proches des citoyens un peu plus
oui il faut leur donner de la liberté
folle en de la donner des capacités
d'innovation vous avez qu'au début de la
crise certaines collectivités faisait
preuve d'innovation faisait preuve
j'allais dire de de volontarisme
essayons de commander en essayant de
commander dès maintenant des détester et
on avait ordres et contre ordres qui
arrivait pas ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que effectivement c'est cette
double préfet services de l'état
déconcentré départementaux et mer au
plus près de la population qui
fonctionne bien et moi je voudrais en
particulier dans le département des
yvelines remercier vraiment nos préfets
et notre adresse départementale parce
qu'on a des liens très forts avec eux et
que les ont servi d'amortisseur entre le
mécontentement des élus locaux qui avait
ordre et contrôler les contemporains de
la population
et puis question et gallienne
un peu difficile donc vraiment on a bien
travaillé ensemble ils font également
dans ce qu'ils peuvent
loches demande à l'état de commander les
vaccins de commandes et dépasse le reste
honnêtement on s'en occupe au niveau
départemental avec les élus locaux et
services déconcentrés de l'état
et c'est ça qui fonctionne la liberté
d'organisation en fonction des
situations
on fait pas la même chose dans un centre
de vaccination par maxime bus data à
bréval ou halo mois que un centre de
vaccination au personnel médical à
versailles ou à sartrouville et donc
c'est vraiment cette intelligence
territoriale qui doit être traité par
les élus locaux avec de liberté des
capacités d'innovation du bon sens et le
soutien de l'état départementale alors
pour avancer peut-être un petit peu dans
cette conversation et cette discussion
autour du pouvoir des maires peut-être
le prochain nous un petit peu en sortons
de cette crise avant sont un petit peu
et puis parlons de la loi de 4 d-4d pour
décentralisation différenciation des
concentrations d complexification la7 ce
projet a été transmis le 18 février
dernier pour avis au conseil d'état il
devrait être présenté fin mars début
avril en conseil des ministres s'inscrit
en première lecture au sénat avant la
fin de la session législative elle
sophie primas à quoi servirait justement
cette nouvelle loi
je crois que dans les dé que vous avez
que vous avez exprimé la dre
complexification et on voit les épisodes
récents et compris quel toute la
complexité l'organisation de l'état je
pense que en cela il ya une grande
attente bien sûr des élus locaux mais
aussi nos concitoyens mais pour parler
plus généralement je crois qu'on est
arrivé à un moment où on devoir se
repositionner sur sur la distribution
des compétences entre
état et les différents niveaux de
collectivités territoriales pour
redonner aux territoires et aux éléments
proximité au collectif collectivités
proximité la capacité de prendre des
décisions et d'affirmer différenciation
en tenant compte des spécificités des
territoires on est vraiment arrivé à ce
moment là où les tailles beaucoup trop
jacobins apprend beaucoup de choses au
niveau global s'en occupe et de
différenciation territoire il est temps
qu'on passe cet acte là c'est vrai bien
sûr dans l'organisation sanitaire telle
qu'on la vit aujourd'hui plus ou moins
bien mais cette valve sur des tas de
sujets c'est vrai sur le développement
économique
c'est vrai sur l'adaptation de la loi
par exemple sur le logement
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels la différenciation
différenciation des territoires doit
être prise en compte
non justement on va demander un
représentant des maires aux présidents
des associations
la dmr des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine à commencer par les
hauts-de-seine les élus locaux attendent
quoi de cette future loi nouvelle loi de
décentralisation d'abord je voudrais
dire tout à l'heure sophie a parlé du
préfet des yvelines j'aurais aussi
préparer des préfet des hauts-de-seine
avec lequel nous entretenons de bonnes
relations et qui ne peut nous donner que
ce que vont bien lui donner donc ça
fonctionne aussi très bien
tout à l'heure on parlait justement des
élus ce qui est important c'est qu'on
prenne des décisions nous même si tout
vient de l'état on n'en sortira pas et
c'était si vrai que pourquoi on est
obligé de passer par l'état pour savoir
si nous devions ouvrir deux salles de
sport si on opte pour les cantines si on
devait regarder pour les jardins publics
regardez ce qui s'est passé il ya
quelques temps on donne on ouvre pour
les fleuristes n'ont fait pas les
fleuristes et dans la nuit on apprend
les fleuristes tout ça c'est pas
décentraliser ses recentraliser donc
faisons très attention à ça on a besoin
de cette centralisation pour définir ce
que nous voulons faire
nous notre responsabilité est engagée à
pierre ou un mois ou tous les autres
maires
le gouvernement n'a pas tellement de
responsabilités vous savez je disais
tout à l'heure c'est pas le gouvernement
que l'on va appeler c'est pas le premier
mis ses paroles bibliques mais c'est le
maire qui
au dessus le maire pourquoi vous faites
pas ce travail pourquoi on vous attend
on a peut-être tout est contre mais
donnons nous les possibilités de le
faire et si cette loi nous permet
d'avoir beaucoup plus de facilité oui
mais vous savez l'administration
centrale
elle est pas très proche des élus pour
essayer de l'île de leur donner du champ
est plutôt recentraliser c'est plus
possible
on ne peut plus dans ce contexte actuel
pour piaf on vous ment j'adhère à
terrassa et viau salue également le
préfet des yvelines et j'associe à ces
remerciements également la grèce parce
qu'en fait la fsc est critiqué de toutes
parts et moi je vois aussi comme tous
les maires les très grandes difficultés
avec d'autres moyens et à cette
administration pour faire face à
l'ampleur du sujet je dirais dans tous
aidé moi j'attends beaucoup mais alors
je mets quelques points d'interrogation
des complexification alors d'abord tous
les gouvernements précédents ont eu un
secrétaire d'état où un ministre pour
lutter pour les simplifications
administratives ou contre la complexité
autre pan on peut pas dire que jusqu'à
présent ces actions ont été marqués d'un
vrai succès et on est un pays qui
produit énormément de normes énormément
de complexité pas seulement dans le cas
de la pandémie mais dans le cadre de
l'action quotidienne et beaucoup de
maires et de citoyens se plaignent
beaucoup parce que cette complexité
n'est pas le gage de l'efficacité bien
au contraire
la deuxième chose sont aussi parlé des
moyens c'est à dire que la
décentralisation sinon aussi confier des
pouvoirs nouveaux ou confier des
fonctions nouvelles
nous sommes présents dans un cadre
aujourd'hui où les moyens dont disposent
les communes se sont réduits la telus
tous les deux il ya quelques années on
voit bien que toute une part de la
fiscalité des djs enfants pourraient
revenir là dessus s'est amoindrie et
donc il faut aussi avoir un certain
nombre de moyens pour faire pour faire
face
et puis là on voit décentralisation il
ya aussi la la déconcentration et c'est
avoir un état au niveau local qui
fonctionne il parle des préfectures on
parle d administration là aussi on a
besoin de gens dans des départements
dans les régions en nombre suffisant
suffisamment équipé pour pouvoir
travailler sinon bah progressivement il
ya quelque chose qui ne fonctionne plus
et on le voit aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui
vous sentez point c'est sur certains
sujets que ce soit l'urbanisme les
transports alors pas uniquement pendant
le cadre de la pandémie mais plus
globalement cette nouvelle loi va
permettre d'avoir les coudées un peu
plus large
moi je l'espère s'adapter à la réalité
du terrain aussi je l'espère et c'est
vrai que nos territoires sont très
différents les uns des autres
même un département d'ile-de-france
comme les yvelines il y à la fois des
zones rurales
il ya des zones urbaines des zones
plutôt aisée des zones plutôt peau enfin
on a de tout et donc il faut savoir
s'adapter sur les territoires après sur
les moyens oui depuis des années on a vu
fondre les dotations globales
une partie de la fiscalité n'est plus
dans le choix
tous peuvent faire un conseil municipal
puisque c'est des mécanismes de
remboursement donc on est un peu
affaibli à ce niveau et voilà il faut
aussi avoir les moyens de faire jacques
osinski quand il faut toujours je
reviens à s'appuyer sur les mers je
pense que c'est eux qui savent
exactement ce qu'ils ont besoin
je rappellerai que un maire est obligé
d'avoir un budget en équilibre
l'état n'est pas obligé d'avoir un
budget en équilibre
c'est la difficulté s'ils étaient
obligés d'avoir un budget en équilibre
je me souviens quand j'ai je fais 20 ans
de députation on avait toujours demander
un petit peu de tout ça paraît très
compliqué
nous on est obligé de faire ça donc on a
besoin de moyens et je disais tout à
l'heure notre responsabilité est
toujours engagé donc c'est vrai qu'on a
besoin d'avoir un peu plus de liberté et
surtout liberté financière car
aujourd'hui avec ce qui se passe où on
peut pas emprunter 150 200 300 milliards
pas possible on est obligé de faire très
attention parce qu'après il faut
rembourser et nous c'est pas sur 15 ans
ou 20 ans donc c'est ça la difficulté
nous n'avons pas assez de possibilité de
faire ce que nous souhaitons parce qu'on
est contrôlé tous les six on nous dit
que si ça fonctionne pas on vous dit au
revoir monsieur le maire
et puis on prend quelqu'un d'autre nous
faisons très attention sophie primas sur
cette future loi qui sera discutée donc
au sénat avant la fin de la session
législative
vous avez déjà des des clauses sur
lesquels vous
ne transigerai pas des points précis sur
lesquels que les que vous voulez voir
apparaître et on va laisser sortir le
projet de loi du conseil d'état pour
essayer de regarder dans le détail vous
savez je j'ai quelques quelques sujets
de prédilection et en particulier
excusez moi sur le logement où là aussi
on va on a beaucoup de demandes des
territoires pour avoir une vraie
politique de décentralisation ou en fait
à la fois sur la construction à la fois
sur l'application de la loi sru à la
fois sur les attributions de logements
on souhaite revenir à des dispositions
qu'ils soient des dispositions plus
proche de territoire moi je serais
extrêmement attentive à ces informations
je voudrais juste pour revenir quelques
instants sur ce que disait 'ca font
évidemment la décentralisation ne veut
qu'avec une déconcentration qui soit
plus importante car il ne s'agit pas de
faire plusieurs france avec des vitesses
d'avancement différents des politiques
publiques et la déconcentration c'est
quand même la garantie que les
politiques publiques sans appliquer que
l'esprit des politiques publiques soient
appliquées partout en france mais que
l'exécution de ces politiques publiques
soit adaptée au territoire ça c'est le
rôle des élus mais c'est vraiment ce
lien là qu'il faut qu'il faut bien
choyés et donc il n'ya pas de
déconcentration et de décentralisation
sans déconcentration c'est vraiment ce
couple-là sur lequel il faut qu'on soit
très attentifs et c'est probablement là
dessus que le sénat aura une très très
très très aiguisé nous allons poursuivre
la conversation avec vous et en plateau
avec les deux présidents des
associations des maires yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine juste après cette
intervention de pierre bédier président
du département des yvelines il ne
pouvait pas être physiquement avec nous
écouter le bo de l'université
et pour tous nos mères illinois et nos
mères des hauts-de-seine puisque
ils seront ensemble ensemble mais pas en
présentiel qu'ovide oblige
hélas quand tous les cas que les uns les
autres soit bien convaincu que le
département des yvelines considère que
la relation entre eux l'institution
départementale et les communes est
absolument essentiel à la stabilité de
notre pays est absolument essentiel à la
satisfaction des besoins de nos
concitoyens
c'est cette conviction qui nous a menés
dans le département des yvelines à nous
efforcer de toujours mieux répondre aux
aspirations des mains dois-je rappeler
la création de cette agence a généré qui
est à la disposition des plus petites
communes qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens de pouvoir intégrer dans leur
personnel communal
toutes les compétences techniques et
juridiques
c'est bien entendu la politique
contractuelle
c'est bien entendu les subventions et en
particulier pour là aussi les petites
communes le tribunal voir et qui permet
un d'avoir dans les yvelines un haut
niveau de service pour les
automobilistes puisque la voiture
n'en déplaise à certains est une
solution de mobilité incontournable dans
un département comme le nôtre voilà
c'est toutes ces actions que le
département des yvelines a engagé
continuera d'engagés
soyez en assurés et permettez moi même
si la saison des voeux est passé de vous
souhaiter une meilleure année enfin
meilleure fin d'année que le début
d'année une fin de la pandémie et
bientôt le plaisir de nous revoir
ensemble donc je vais faire une annonce
qui en c'est l'occasion c'est si c'est
possible nous retrouverons mi-juillet
pas le 14 parce que nous avons tous des
obligations pas forcément le 13 au soir
parce qu'il y aura sans doute des feux
d'artifice mais peut-être le 12 juin peu
avant nous nous retrouverons tous
ensemble les maires des yvelines les
maires des hauts-de-seine pour une
soirée républicaine pour le plaisir de
retrouver cette convivialité qui
manquent top bonne université à toutes
et à tous l'invitation est donc lancée
avec les beaucoup d'optimisme par le
président du département des yvelines
pour cette soirée républicaine et on
l'espère à l'ecosite feu d'artifice le
13 et la célébration de la fête
nationale le 14
en attendant nous poursuivrons cette
ouverture des universités des mairies
78,92 donc ouverture aujourd'hui si vous
nous rejoignez sur tv 78 pour avec cette
émission et puis il y en aura d'autres
un tout au long de l'après-midi à suivre
en direct au replay sur notre site
internet et puis dès demain hélas le
programme elle sera retrouvée sur le
site de l'université des mairies
universités des mairies point fr pour
avoir le détail de la programmation à
partir de mardi et tous les séminaires
qui sont proposés pour les collectivités
de l'ouest parisien parler du on est
entendu pierre bédier parlant du travail
avec le département justement comment se
passe ce travail ce couple mère
département c'est un couple historique
c'est à dire que l'organisation
administrative française a été conçu
comme ça depuis la révolution française
c'est à dire qu'il ya des communes qui
sont l'autorité territoriale la plus
ancienne et puis au moment de la
création des départements s'est instauré
ce couple qui est un couple fort du dd
des communes avec les départements et
rappelez-vous chaque fois qu'il y a eu
des réflexions sur des réformes sur la
suppression du département son
adaptation etc on est toujours revenu en
fait sur la nécessité de fonctionnement
de ce couple
alors bien évidemment il ya d'autres
aussi relation est la relation avec la
région qui est essentiel également la
région est souvent un peu plus lointaine
et le mode électoral n'est pas le même
alors on rend un peu d'ordre là la
cuisine électorale mais c'est c'est ça
aussi c'est à dire que le département
les élus départementaux sont des élus
qui sont élus dans le cadre d'une
circonscription territoriale qui
s'appelle le canton et donc ils ont
naturellement une relation avec les
mères puisque c'est cette élection de
territoire avec une personne avant et de
personnes aujourd'hui mais c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne et donc il ya ce
lien régulier qui va au delà des routes
des collèges de l'action sociale qui
sont les compétences départementales
mais qui vont aussi sur la solidarité au
sein des territoires entre les
territoires les plus modestes et les
plus aisés et c est ça c'est le
département qui en grande partie
d'organismes et pour les yvelines ça
fonctionne plutôt bien
à travers ça fonctionne très bien et
depuis toujours avec des objectifs
partagés un cas à la fois un objet du
d'économies devant son public et
d'efficacité aussi de la dépense pour
permettre un développement harmonieux du
territoire avant de vous poser la
question du côté des hauts-de-seine je
vous propose d'écouter le président des
hauts-de-seine à présent georges
siffredi également qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas être avec nous en plateau et ni par
par visio mais il enregistré une petite
vidéo
mesdames et messieurs les maires mais
mes chers collègues bonjour à vous tous
le thème donc aujourd'hui est de
répondre à la question qui nous est
posée qui est la réponse que nous avons
amené les uns les autres ensemble à la
crise économique et surtout sanitaires
que nous avons eus à assumer inconnu
subissons encore depuis maintenant un
peu plus donnant les premières décisions
que nous avons pris dans notre
département dès que le premier
confinement est apparu
ça a été de dépister immédiatement les
ehpad les résidences autonomie et
également les personnels qui étaient
attachées à la fois aux ehpad et l'esad
puisque ça nous paraissait important
mais nous avons également acquis de
façon massive
un grand nombre plusieurs millions
de masques pour pouvoir distribuer
également aux populations à travers vous
les maires les communes puisque c'est
vous qui après avait été le lien entre
le département et nos concitoyens et
puis pour pas que nos jeunes qui étaient
confinés puisque tout était fermé
puis c'est trop séparer du milieu
scolaire nous avons également hélas
ensemble grâce au numérique achetés et
mis à disposition une sa tombe de deux
tablettes pour que l'ensemble des
collégiens en particulier dans les
quartiers les plus sensibles en
difficulté puissent bénéficier donc de
ces instruments pour pouvoir continuer à
avoir un lien avec le collège est
étudiée puis après très vite n'y a pas
eu des difficultés pour des populations
qui avaient peu de ressources pour nos
petites entreprises nos commerçants donc
là immédiatement aussi rapidement nous
avons agi pour apporter une aide directe
aux petits commerces et aux petites
entreprises
c'est 30 millions d'euros que nous avons
débloqué voter dans notre département
pour
les aider est également donc auprès des
communes qui elle-même devait faire face
à ce homme de problème là nous allons
avoir apporté une aide équivalente à 10
euros par habitant étaient représentés
pour l'ensemble du département
16 millions ennemis de nos populations
également d' qui étaient parfois et bien
souvent en difficulté toutes les
personnes qui étaient à la prime
d'activité nous avons là aussi décider
de leur troyer sur la situation
familiale entre 150 euros et 400 euros
par foyer qui là aussi ça représentait
une somme globale de 18 millions d'euros
au global nous en sommes aujourd'hui
et c'est pas terminé puisque la crise
talité à la crise sociale continue nous
en sommes pour notre département à 120
millions d'euros
donc globalement de dépenses mais je
vous avais donné les grandes lignes je
vais pas tout détailler parce que ça
serait bien là l'essentiel de tout cela
c'est quoi et en conclusion c'est qu'en
réalité nous avons démontré une fois
encore nos départements et vous qui êtes
de merck et autres plus proches dont le
vois bien encore maintenant avec les
centres de vaccination et bien que nous
sommes vraiment les collectivités de
proximité qui pouvons nous adapter très
vite prendre les bonnes mesures
et en même temps avoir les moyens qu'ils
soient en personnel qui soit en
réactivité mais qu'ils soient même
financiers pour répondre aux
problématiques de terrain et donc s'il
fallait encore prouvé que les communes
et les départements doivent exister
parce que il faut encore et c'est eux
qui répondent aux problématiques de
proximité de la démonstration en est
fait je suis désolé de ne pas pouvoir
être en votre compagnie mais ça fait
partie des problématiques de cette crise
sanitaire
mais je vous souhaite de bons débats et
j'espère pouvoir vous retrouver très
rapidement et que nous puissions
réellement échanger débattre discuter
ensemble différemment que ce que je
viens de faire
à l'instant nous allons parler du
travail département mer dans les
yvelines parlons de la même chose mais
du côté des hauts-de-seine à présent
dans les hauts-de-seine bien entendu
cela fonctionne aussi est d'ailleurs
quand un moment
le gouvernement ou les hommes politiques
on souhaitait avant de supprimer sa
certains supprimer les départements
ça nous a permis de se rapprocher du 78
68 du 92
sinon ça aurait été quand même beaucoup
plus difficile et on s'est aperçu quoi
on s'est aperçu que les départements
apporter quelque chose et aider rien un
moment aussi le sourire l'assemblée
nationale et ç'avait été votée
d'ailleurs c'était le département et la
région
faire un conseiller territorial ça aussi
ça avait été envisagé et puis bon le
gouvernement d'un fan a changé d'adressé
passer à gauche et ça a été arrêté alors
y avait une question là je ne sais pas
pourquoi c'était peut-être pour réduire
le nombre toujours parce que vous savez
la population s'imagine toujours que les
députés que les maires que les conseils
départementaux et conseils régionaux ça
fait beaucoup d'argent parce que c'est
sa force pas se voiler la face
arrêté c'était pour essayer de faire des
économies de résultats c'est pas ça
résultat c'était qu'est ce qui était
plus fort pour s'en sortir et basson
sortir c'était les départements laisser
des départements comme ils sont et je
pense que les 92 est un département un
petit peu différent des autres c'est
pour ça je veux pas trop en parler parce
que on est assez jalouse et si vous
voulez ah c'est vrai parce que on a
quand même un centre européen des
affaires gay l'a donc qu'est la défense
et qui amène beaucoup c'est bien
d'autres du faut pas se voiler la face
par rapport aux 78 et puis on a une
densité beaucoup plus importante si vous
voulez que dans le 78 mais justement
c'est ce qui est complémentaire
c'est pour ça que les deux présidents se
sont rapprochés je pense que ça
continuera
et je pense que c'est vrai nous dans les
collectivités locales si le département
n'était pas donnerait beaucoup
difficulté il nous aide beaucoup
je crois c'est intéressant paul ont
effectivement si ces deux départements
sont amenés à travailler encore plus
ensemble par la suite déjà parce qu'il y
aura aussi des élections normalement qui
devrait se tenir normalement au mois de
juin élections départementales et
régionales aussi mais ce sera sans doute
l'un des points de deux programmes des
différents candidats et ce sera
l'occasion d'échanger plus largement sur
cette thématique là nous parlons tout à
l'heure du pouvoir des maires avec une
réforme à venir cette loi de
décentralisation
il ya aussi une autre situation qui
pourrait être amené à évoluer grâce à un
renforcement de la loi
c'est la question des pouvoirs des
maires en matière de sécurité avec la
loi sécurité globale ce qui leur à des
adaptations ou pas pour les mères au
quotidien ils sont souvent démunis face
à la montée de la violence parfois même
des plus jeunes elle sophie primas je me
tourne vers vous en tant que sénatrice
il ya des améliorations des choses qui
vont pouvoir arriver pour pour les
mettre dans la gestion des difficultés
de sécurité alors juste quelques
instants je prends quelques quelques
minutes pour vous dire que nous avons
voté la version sénat de la loi sécurité
globale la semaine dernière et il ne
vous a pas échappé que ça s'est fait
dans le calme absolu
le premier jour où nous avons voté cette
loi qui avait été très discuté un peu
avec quelques violences à l'assemblée
nationale le sénat a joué son rôle
d'apaisement par rapport à l' équilibre
qui était challenge pour cette loi et
son fameux article 24 entre la
protection de nos forces de l'ordre et
les libertés individuelles carte est
d'informer cette loi a été votée la
semaine dernière dans la sérénité
senna et nous avons essayé justement de
trouver cet équilibre entre liberté
individuelle et protection pour ce qui
est des pouvoirs des maires en
particulier nous avons beaucoup
travaillé sur le petit train qui était
le premier chapitre qui qui prévoit des
extensions en fait des prérogatives
judiciaires des agents de police
municipale
donc là aussi nous avons agréé cette
expérimentation
cette expérimentation nous souhaitons
qu'elle soit mené dans les communes à
partir du moment où il ya 15 policier
municipal municipaux pardon au moins
c'est une expérimentation que nous
souhaitons mener sur 5 ans et moins
d'énergie en fait que les possibilités
et les pouvoirs des policiers municipaux
mais on le fait nous avons rajouté au
sénat l'obligation également de
formation tout est une question
d'équilibré si on demande plus aux
policiers municipaux
eh bien il faut leur apporter également
plus de formations plus de liens plus de
moyens
localement pour pouvoir agir plus
efficacement
voilà je donnais peut-être un exemple
bien particulier mais je pense que ça
parlera au maire qui peuvent vous
écoutez nous souhaitons leur donner plus
de pouvoirs notamment pour constater les
infractions liées à l'occupation
illicite des terrains publics notamment
celle des problématiques parce que nous
avons mais arrivés nombreux c'est
important de gens du voyage ou des
délits de par exemple de de rodéo
motorisés qui font florès dans nos
quartiers et dans nos villes voilà des
expérimentations qui sont pour nous
extrêmement importantes à mener au
niveau local la loi sécurité globale va
changer les choses
vous pensez et mairie ils le font parce
que le thème de la sécurité est un thème
qui est de plus en plus fort moi moi je
suis souvent surpris quand on fait des
réunions avec les maires parfois dans
des territoires qui n'était pas connu
pour rencontrer des problèmes de
sécurité que cette thématique est
devenue la première et donc il ya
aujourd'hui un développement de la
délinquance de la sécurité d'incivilité
vous l'appelez comme vous voulez et en
tout cas sur l'ensemble du territoire et
pas seulement comme c'était plus le cas
auparavant dans certains quartiers ou
dans certaines villes et beaucoup de
communes sont très démuni par rapport à
ces problématiques sont parce qu'elles
n'ont pas de police municipale soit
parce que la gendarmerie et la police
est plus loin et et nos concitoyens
c'est une demande régulière
que ce soit les squats par exemple la
presse on a beaucoup parlé ces derniers
temps
l'occupation de terrains les rodéos les
rodéos c'est quand même on n'est pas
dans la grande délinquance mais en
aidant une délinquance ce qui si vous me
permettez l'expression pourrit la vie
pendant tout l'été de milliers de
franciliens et donc il faut qu'on soit
en capacité de répondre à sale en moi je
le souhaite
les polices municipales sont un fait
elles se sont profondément développer et
professionnaliser
ces dernières années je crois que dans
beaucoup de communes aujourd'hui elles
ont un vrai niveau tout à fait
comparable à la police nationale il ya
une bonne relation police nationale
police municipale est donc effectivement
il faut renforcer
les pouvoirs du maire dans un certain
nombre d'actions qui celle dont parle et
où sophie primas par exemple on devra se
souvenir pourquoi on a des polices
municipales et pourquoi certaines villes
peuvent le faire et d'autre ne peut
passer ça coûte quand même simplement
parce que l'état n'a pas fait son
travail
on aurait dû avoir que la police
nationale ou de la gendarmerie
on n'aurait pas dû avoir de la police
municipale c'est bien que certaines
villes qui ont un budget peuvent le
faire sinon c'est pas une bonne chose
alors maintenant si on l'a comme tu
viens de dire
on a besoin d'avoir des moyens vous
savez que quand on arrête un délinquant
la presse philippe aladel un coffre
qu'elle appelle au pgi pour l'irak est
ce que je peux faire
elle n'a pas le droit de dire donnez moi
vos papiers d'identité pas le droit donc
il ya un moment il faut savoir ce que
l'on veut où on nous donne des moyens de
le faire et à ce moment là toujours prêt
à le faire sous la responsabilité du
maire d'ailleurs faut pas l'oublier
c'est toujours responsabilité du maire
ou alors on nous dit on ne voit pas donc
cette fois elle a tout intérêt à le
faire et ce film déjà quelque chose on
autonome des moyens des moyens non pas
financiers même si on pouvait en avoir
mais s'avoue pas y compter et on peut
seul tour avoir des moyens disons de
l'ec légaux pour l'on puisse arrêter là
quelque chose aussi qui m'inquiète un
tout petit peu est ce qu'un jour là je
vais lancer un pavé dans la mare que ces
polices municipales et là je sais quand
on aura le sénat certainement qu'il sera
avec nous l'assemblée de ça dépendra de
la sensibilité neuvien ne serait pas un
jour prises par la police nationale
comme on a le contingent des pompiers où
on donne de l'argent est très bien pour
le fun c'est si on ne se pose pas et un
jour se dire qu'après tout la police
municipale de la follia la police
nationale veulent prendre en charge et
ils vont faire et les villes perret
faisons très attention
je me retourne vers le sénat ben là
c'est assez souvent très attention à ça
quinze jours on est
attention le politique prend directement
sur nes à l'intérieur je ne suis pas se
seraient prêts à voter une indexation
des policiers municipaux part en part
par l'état mais le sénat c'est la
barrière je sais que là on a deux
voitures
voilà sa fille primat a entendu le
message
vous parliez on va il nous reste une
dizaine de minutes en a pas c'est encore
ensemble
sophie primas oui oui pardon pardon pour
vous mais une loi sécurité globale en
matière en matière de soutien aux mères
ne sera pas la seule parce que savait
qu'on allait la loi le projet de voir
valeurs de la république séparatisme
enfin sait plus trop comment la paix qui
va arriver et qu'il va aussi pour
définir des outils pour les mères qui
sont extrêmement importants il ya
aujourd'hui des maires qui sont dans des
difficultés notamment parce qu'on leur
demande beaucoup de choses très
difficiles on leur demande des régimes
particuliers dans les cantines et donc
en réaffirmant les valeurs de la
république dans ce futur projet de loi
qui va arriver la semaine prochaine au
sénat
il ya aussi une redéfinition j'allais
dire des principes républicains qui
pourront être très utile au vert pour
avoir vraiment la ligne qu'il soit la
ligne politique républicaine qui peut
tenir dans leur l'exécution de leurs
missions municipales
il nous reste une dizaine de minutes à
passer ensemble nous allons écouter à
présent la présidence de la région
ile-de-france valérie pécresse qui elle
aussi a tenu à intervenir pour cette
émission qui marque l'ouverture des
universités des mairies 78 92
mesdames et messieurs les maires
j'aurais été heureuse de croiser chacun
d'entre vous comme nous en avions
l'habitude mais c'est déjà une très
bonne chose que ce rendez vous
incontournable puisse se tenir cette
année dans un format qui malheureusement
commence à nous être family nous vivons
une période terriblement difficile et je
voudrais avant tout avoir une pensée
très amicale pour ceux d'entre vous qui
sont ou qui ont été durement touchés par
la pandémie
la région de france et le territoire le
plus marqué par la crise sanitaire
mais aussi à la crise économique et
sociale et ce contexte particulier va
malheureusement se poursuivre mais c'est
un message d'espoir que je suis venu
porter aujourd'hui car j'ai confiance en
nous tous responsables nous le sommes
depuis le départ et nous le resterons
dans la gestion de la crise sanitaire
la région sera à vos côtés pour que
jamais mobilisée pour la santé des
franciliens
nous continuerons de vous proposer des
journées de dépistage dans vos communes
dont les lycées bien évidemment avec des
bus qui sillonnent la région
vous savez 50 gares franciliennes ont
été dotés le point de dépistage approche
de proximité
consciente du coût considérable de la
crise pour aux collectivités la région a
mis en place un fonds vaccinale régional
pour vous aider à financer
l'installation et le fonctionnement de
vos centres de vaccination pour
faciliter vos démarches
mais rendre plus sûre et moins coûteuse
la centrale d'achat régional est
toujours à votre disposition pour vous
équiper en purificateurs d'air en
masquant gel en test durant ce nouveau
confinement
la région sera aux côtés des plus
vulnérables en continuant de proposer
des distributions alimentaires dans vos
communes mais aussi pour nos étudiants
sur les campus
les jeunes sont particulièrement touchés
et nous ne les oublions pas pour lutter
contre les difficultés financières et la
détresse psychologique des étudiants et
les apprentis
la région ile de france a mis en place
dans le cadre de son programme région
solidaire un plan de secours composée de
plusieurs mesures phares à destination
des étudiants franciliens une plateforme
de conseil et le consultation
psychologique gratuite
écoute étudiant en ile-de-france point
fr nous leur avons mis à disposition des
hôtels pour leur logement d'urgence donc
garantie 115
prêt étudiant auprès de banques
quand les familles ne peuvent plus être
caution et nous avons aidé à leurs
équipements informatiques
de la même façon nous proposons un
revenu jeune actif de 4000 euros pour
les jeunes sans emploi et sans formation
670 euros par mois pour des formations
de six mois dans les métiers qui
aujourd'hui ils recrutent
car il y en a beaucoup et c'est le
paradoxe de cette crise des métiers à
l'arrêt des métiers qui recrutent et la
région qui l'a pour convertir
professionnellement il demandeurs
d'emploi et les jeunes la région
n'oublie pas évidemment ces entreprises
vous le savez notre fonds résilience
créé par la région la banque des
territoires avec le soutien de 70
collectivités locales et du département
des hauts-de-seine est destiné à
soutenir les tpe les micro entreprises
des associations et les acteurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
d'ile-de-france impacté par la crise
sanitaire
je remercie la métropole durant paris la
ville de paris et 71 intercommunalités
d'avoir été en soutien de ce dispositif
ce fonds offre une avance remboursable
de 3000 à 5000 euros à tous ceux qui
n'ont pas ou plus accès aux financements
bancaires
par ailleurs la région vous le savez
propose une aide au paiement des loyers
de 1000 euros forfaitaire pour les
commerces les restaurants les cafés de
moins de 10 salariés ce qui ont été
fermés pendant le précédent confinement
et ceux qui sont confirmés
aujourd'hui nous venons de lancer un
appel à projet tpe pme pour aider les
tpe pme porteuses d'une stratégie de
croissance et créatrices d'emplois pour
aider les entreprises en difficulté à
trouver la bonne information est le bon
interlocuteur pour les guider et les
accompagne au mieux
nous avons un smart services qui
s'appelle assiste entreprises
et dans l'immédiat nous faisons tout
pour que notre système de santé tiennent
c'est pourquoi la région déploie un
programme innovant pour augmenter et
améliorer les capacités de réanimation
des hôpitaux publics et privés
francilien avec la création de 500 lits
de réanimation modulaire sur fonds
européens mes chers amis les semaines à
venir s'annoncent difficiles à vivre
pour les franciliens et nous devons nous
serrer tous ri coude mais je crois aussi
en notre extraordinaire potentiel et
dans votre dynamisme pour que la crise
que nous traversons débouche sur une
croissance retrouvée et sur une nouvelle
qualité d'élite avec la transition
écologique avec un plan de relance qui
est inédit
là aussi par son ampleur dans le pays
un plan de relance de 13 milliards 800
millions d'euros que nous allons mener
la main dans la main avec l'état et
évidemment avec les maires car vous
serez les porteurs de projet de ce plan
de relance et je viendrai vous promenez
vous proposez et vous présenter toutes
les actions du plan de relance très
bientôt dans le cadre de nos réunions
zoom habituel pour que vous sachiez
comment actionner les différents
dispositifs de ce plan de relance de 13
mai à 800 millions d'euros que nous
mettrons en oeuvre avec l'état pour nous
relever plus fort je vous remercie
la région qui compte sur l'intervention
des merengues en relais qui sera fait et
des échanges deuxième souhaité on va
juste coup le retour le retour du
plateau puisqu'il ya un sens
supplémentaire voilà
gaffe on voit là sur cet échange avec la
région parle en bas la région a été très
présent dès le départ un sur le soutien
sanitaire puisque je rappelle que la
région était la première à mettre à
disposition des maires des possibilités
d'achat de masques de matériel dès le
mois de mars dernier donc la réactivité
de la région les constantes et le volet
que valérie pécresse évoque sur l'aspect
économique soutient de commerce est
essentiel essentiel dans toutes nos
communes parce que on le voit tous nos
commerces de centre ville
alors certains sont ouverts d'autres
fermés la logique de la fermeture d un
de nous deux autres ne soient pas
toujours aux yeux mais ceux qui sont
fermés souffre terriblement
et donc il faut à tout prix faire en
sorte qu'on puisse les aider
financièrement et donc les maires seront
bien évidemment présents répondre
présent pour faire en sorte que le
maximum d'entreprises tout petits
commerces grande survival a pas d'amis
et se présente demain
ça fait plaisir d'écouter une présidente
quand les plaisir d'écouter deux
présidents d'une présidente de région
ile de france
parce que mon sac est une région qui a
des moyens mais ses ouailles on en
profite et elle le dit el had s'ils ont
peut-être que la diva est tout à fait
raison je pense que dans la ville je
suis on a beaucoup d'entreprises bien
entendu puisqu'on est proche comme je
disais de la défense eh bien ils sont
ravis qu'on puisse les aider
et puis les petits commerçants sont
ravis aussi qu'on vient de leur donner
mais les départements aussi donne
puisque le département des
hauts-de-seine soffer c'était 30
millions d'euros pour les déserts les
commerces
donc ils sont ravis donc on a le
département et la région
cdg vraiment deux institutions qui
fonctionnent très bien faudrait pas
d'autosatisfaction c'est la réalité des
choses vérité des chiffres par les deux
chiffres peut-être une réalité qui ne
faut pas masquer non plus et les
difficultés financières derrière tout ça
parce qu'on appelle temps de l'aborder
ce sera peut-être le mot de conclusion
je vais vous demander dans un instant
ils ont apparemment paravent remercier
sophie primas merci d'avoir participé à
cette émission d'ouverture de des
universités des mairies yvelines et
hauts-de-seine
ce dernier mot de conclusion adressée au
maire peut-être je voudrais vraiment
remercier la mobilisation des maires
parce que l'année dernière n'oublions
pas nous étions à l'aîné année
électorale il ya des mères qui ont été
reconduits il ya aussi des nouveaux
verts qui ont pris leurs fonctions dans
des conditions extrêmement difficiles de
mise en août de relation avec les
services de l'état avec leurs
populations
mais vraiment je voudrais les saluer
tous parce que c'est par leur
implication leur présence sur le terrain
que nos concitoyens aujourd'hui ils
peuvent regarder
voilà les mois qui viennent avec un
petit peu plus d'optimisme
en tout cas vraiment merci à eux et
merci à vous d'avoir organisé cette
table merci sophie primas bien fond je
vous passe la parole ce sera le tour de
table d'hôte de conclusion j'ai abordé
brièvement la question des finances la
réalité derrière aujourd'hui c'est que
les finances des communes sont peut-être
un petit peu compliqué aussi la crise à
la crise n'a pas arrangé les choses
ou alors elles ont toujours été mais
elles le sont beaucoup plus et il ya
quelques années lors de mon premier
mandat
quand je compare on avait des moyens
beaucoup plus importants d'actions et
aujourd'hui beaucoup moins et les
nouveaux maires sont encore plus
confrontés à la fois au grand écart
entre des demandes croissantes de leurs
concitoyens justifié légitime et puis
d'un autre côté des moyens qui se
raréfie il faut laisser les maires en
capacité de faire et d'agir savez la
france c'est avant tout c'est 36000
communes ses milliers de conseillers
municipaux qui travaillent bien commun
et qui rendent un service inouïe à la
fois aux français et à la france tout
court et donc il faut vraiment faire en
sorte que ces moyens soient au rendez
vous qu'on puisse travailler qu'on ne
t'a pas toute son énergie dans des
dossiers complexes et c est qu on puisse
renforcer l'action au niveau communal
jacques osinski moi j'ai des inquiétudes
de nous laisser travailler
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure et une
chose que nous savons faire c'est
maîtriser nos dépenses
une sauce ne savons pas faire c'est nos
recettes donc il va falloir que l'on
fasse le maximum parce que la population
elle veut toujours avoir le même niveau
de vie elle comprend pas que vous n'ayez
pas le financement pour elle quand elle
a des difficultés faut que le maire soit
là je pense que l'état qui transfère des
charges
au début c'est très bien c'est zéro
centime et puis demain c'est j'oublie je
fais plus et c'est ça la difficulté
je crois que si les collectivités
locales financièrement ne peuvent pas
subvenir à leurs besoins c'est une
catastrophe pour la france c'est pas
spécialement les cas je vous dis type
taux d'alors l'état peut toujours
emprunter ou un peu de champ planté mais
font bon c'est bien beau mais il faut un
budget en équilibre
rappelons ça toujours un budget en
équilibre ce que l'état ne fait pas et
nous je sais dans nos villes j'ai pas me
plaindre tôt parce que ce par une ville
trop malheureuse je le dis mais quand
vous n'êtes pas trop malheureux c'est
parce que vous donnez beaucoup aussi
quand on dit vous avez ou dépenses et où
on dépense parce qu'on a des besoins et
on s'aperçoit que la population dans nos
villes est de plus en plus disons en
difficulté et donc il faut qu'on réponde
présent les commerçants aussi sont en
difficulté il faut répondre présent
l'adie commerçants on savait qu'ils sont
vraiment aujourd'hui dans des situations
très difficiles et c'est pour ça que je
terminerais là dedans on a besoin de
psychologues pour aider que ce soit dans
les écoles que ce soit dans les cycles
de charge aussi dans nos villes on a
besoin parce que les gens sont
complètement dérouté ça plus du tout où
ils vont merci à tous les deux est
revenu sur ce plateau et pour évoquer
les différentes questions les différents
sujets qui préoccupent
elle est mère c'était l'ouverture de ces
universités des mairies à 78,92 si vous
nous suivez en direct dans un instant
sur tv 78 patrice carmouze évoquera avec
ses invités
la question de la gestion des communes
rurales et des communes urbaines avec
plusieurs intervenants maire de magny
les hameaux ou encore de meudon de mon
côté je vous retrouve donc un peu plus
d'une demi-heure vers 15 heures pour
parler de sécurité bonne après midi sur
tv 78
[Musique]